دعونا نذهب الان الى اميره مصطفى عطا
المنان وهي موظفه في مستشفى الخرطوم
التعليمي حتى تعطينا صوره واضحه عن وضع
المستشفيات ووضع الجرحى هناك اميره اهلا
بك معنا هل يمكن ان تصفي لنا وضع مستشفى
الخرطوم التعليمي واذا كان لديك اي
معلومات عن المستشفيات الاخرى
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
تفضل يا ست اميره هل سمعت السؤال
نعم تفضلي
انا راشد من مستشفى الخرطوم والتعليمي
الخرطومه التعليمي حاليا المستشفى يشغل
جميع اللغومات الحياه
من مياه وكهرباء
وجبات للطعام
لا توجد ادويه
والكادر الطبي غير متوفر
بالناشد انه
ينقل لنا المرضى من مسلسل الخرطوم
لاقرب مستشفى في جبره او ابن سينا
مع من تتصلون اميره حتى يتمكنوا من نقل
هؤلاء الجرحى هل هناك من اتصالات حتى يكون
هناك ممر امن تستطيعون بعده اخراج هؤلاء
الجرحى والمرضى من المستشفى
نعم نعم
في زملائنا في المستشفى في داخل المستشفى
هم الى الان محتجزون هناك
نعم
متواصلين معاهم وهم الان
كان عندهم محاوله في انهم يصلحوا يعملوا
صيانه
المولد الكهربائي ولكن بدون جدوى
اذا الوضع في مستشفى الخرطوم التعليمي كما
تتحدثين اميره يعني لا كهرباء ولا مياه
وانتم تناشدون بنقل المرضى والجرحى من من
هذه المستشفى هل لديك اي احصائيه مثلا عن
الجرح الذين دخلوا الى مستشفى الخرطوم
التعليمي هل لديك من ارقام
ما في ارقام محدده ما في ارقام محدده لانه
في جزء منه امس كلهم وحاليا الموجودين
ولكن الاعداد كبيره
الاعداد كبيره يعني ليس لديك من احصائيه
ولكن اقله هل اعداد كبيره التي دخلت الى
هذا المستشفى
المستشفى
لم يدخل ليها يعني الجرحى ولكن
هم جميعهم مرضى في
غرف الانعاش
والاصابات حدثت داخل المستشفى للمواطنين
شكرا لك من نعم شكرا لك يا اميره مصطفى
عطا المنان وظف في مستشفى الخرطوم
التعليمي لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات